businesses now operating at half  capacity here in southern nevada but not  having conventions the past year has  been a huge economic loss for las vegas  but governor steve siselek says he is  confident they will be back  nevada will be the safest place to have  a convention  or come and visit will be safe for the  tourists  and business travelers will be safe for  employees  and will be safe for their families  lvcva says the world of concrete  is coming to the expanded convention  center in june  by then the monorail and the underground  people mover should be up and running  that'll be exciting  fashion trade show magic returns in  august and in october  supply side west for food and beverage  manufacturers  also returns to las vegas that is some  good news